With Hollywood cranking out blockbuster fare
at a staggering rate, and arthouse cinema
fully coming into its own, the '90s were an
excitingly mixed bag at the multiplex.
This combination of high and low art carried
over into video stores too, inspiring movie
buffs to scour shelves for both big-budget
bonanzas and obscure festival hits.
Sadly, those searches often proved fruitless,
leaving some of the decade's best films largely
unseen by the masses.
Here are a few '90s gems that are absolutely
worthy of your attention — if you can track
them down, that is.
Twin Peaks: Fire Walk With Me
No single show changed the landscape of television
in the '90s more than David Lynch's supernatural
murder mystery Twin Peaks.
Even after a game-changing first season, the
show was unceremoniously cancelled in the
midst of its wildly uneven second season.
Once the show ended, fans were delighted to
find out that Lynch still had Twin Peaks tales
to tell.
One of those tales — that of Laura Palmer's
last week on Earth — got the big screen
treatment in Twin Peaks: Fire Walk With Me.
Free from the creative shackles of television,
Lynch used the chance to craft his most complex,
uncompromising film to date.
Sadly, even the most devoted of Twin Peaks'
fanbase had trouble connecting with Fire Walk
With Me's artsy eccentricities.
The film proved divisive amongst critics,
all but ignored in its theatrical release,
and unfairly doomed to a sort of purgatory
in the process.
For all of its quirks, Fire Walk With Me stands
as a creative high point for Lynch, breathlessly
combining his penchant for experimentation
with his trademarked biting commentary on
the American dream.
Though the film has had its defenders over
the years, and has long held the title of
"cult classic," it still feels like not enough
people have actually seen it.
Chaplin
Before Robert Downey Jr. put Marvel on the
map with his now iconic turn in Iron Man,
Richard Attenborough tapped him to star in
his Charlie Chaplin bio-pic, appropriately
titled Chaplin.
Lucky for Attenborough — and for film buffs
everywhere — Downey Jr. turned in the finest
performance of his young career, landing RDJ
his first Oscar nomination.
But Attenborough's film is more than just
a showcase for Downey Jr.'s talent.
Though it didn't fare well with critics who
lamented its 143-minute runtime and overall
lack of ingenuity, Chaplin remains a lovingly
crafted, in-depth look behind the curtain
of one of cinema's greatest innovators.
The film is likely to inspire viewers to go
back and explore Chaplin's own mind-blowing
body of work as well, not to mention the mostly
terrific work Downey Jr. has delivered in
the years since Chaplin's release.
Red Rock West
Things have certainly gotten away from Nicolas
Cage over the past decade or so, but throughout
the '90s he was still deemed an exciting,
supremely talented actor, the sort who could
handle big-budget fare but still wow in micro-budget
indies.
So it came as no surprise that he'd follow
one of his biggest box office hits — Honeymoon
In Vegas — by starring as a wayward drifter
in John Dahl's Red Rock West.
Don't worry if you've never heard of the brilliant
neo-noir thriller.
The film's been all but lost to history since
its release — which is a shame, because
Dahl's nimble tale of small-town swindling
and mistaken identity is just as slick today
as it was back in 1996.
It also happens to feature one of Cage's most
understated and effecting performances.
With any luck, the aging actor might one day
remember that, sometimes, less actually is
more — especially when bees are involved.
"Not not the bees.
"not the bees."
Ah."
"My eyes.
My eyes.
Ah"
Dick
Back in 1999, a political satire titled Dick
should've gotten a lot more attention than
it did.
Sadly, in the almost two decades since the
comedy's release, the film still hasn't found
its audience.
With any luck, however, the current political
climate might change that.
After all, the girl-power-centric story of
political upheaval carries as much weight
today as it might have in the year it was
set.
The fact that Dick also features winning performances
from Kirsten Dunst, Michelle Williams, and
Dan Hedaya as a brilliant Nixon caricature
makes it even more worthy of notice.
Full of insightful stoner-styled comedy, and
featuring a terrific supporting cast of gifted
comedians, Dick is a must-see that too many
moviegoers missed the first time around.
Ghost Dog: The Way of the Samurai
Loosely adapted from Jean-Pierre Melville's
New Wave classic, Le Samurai, 1999's Ghost
Dog: The Way of the Samurai sees notoriously
experimental director Jim Jarmusch at his
most accessible.
Whereas Le Samurai saw its titular silent
assassin skulking around the back alleys of
Paris, Forest Whitaker's eponymous Ghost Dog
calls the mean streets of Brooklyn home.
Jarmusch bolstered the film's spiritual insights
by frequently quoting Samurai philosophy and
backed his sword-swinging killer's gritty,
urban journey with a head-nodding original
score from Wu Tang Clan's RZA.
Combining ancient warrior wisdom with a stylish
hip-hop vibe, Jarmusch spins an engrossing
and deeply satisfying story of modern-day
honor amongst thieves that still resonates
with film fanatics today.
Stir of Echoes
The ripple effect from The Sixth Sense's breakout
success is still being felt in Hollywood today;
in other words, it seems like every modern
horror film comes prepackaged with its own
flashy, twist ending.
Now, imagine that you released a haunting
horror film rife with unsettling imagery — and,
yes, a shocking twist — a mere month after
The Sixth Sense changed the horror game.
Even if your film was just as clever and scary
as M. Night Shyamalan's masterpiece, it'd
be virtually impossible to match those Sixth
Sense-sized expectations.
Such was the case with David Koepp's Stir
of Echoes.
Following the trials and tribulations of a
working-class dad who starts to experience
terrifying visions after a hypnosis hiccup,
Koepp's film is often just as smart and creepy
as The Sixth Sense.
At times, Stir of Echoes even bests Shyamalan's
flick on both fronts, but it also features
a child who can speak to dead people, so yeah,
you can see the problem with its being released
after Haley Joel Osment uttered those now
iconic words.
"I see dead people."
Still, Stir of Echoes is far from a cheap
knock off, and horror fans unfamiliar with
the unsung flick owe it to themselves to give
it a shot.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!